let's talk about it how to be a
non-threat don't ask tough questions yep
don't ask technical questions don't ask
why questions don't talk about yourself
don't talk about yourself don't touch
politics don't touch world events or
those some of the ways you correct look
put together but don't look like you put
effort into yourself don't wear your
money don't wear money on your wrist
don't wear money on your fingers don't
wear money on your clothes show up on
time not earlier late
um why is that because if you show up
early then people remember that because
usually you catch people by surprise if
you show up late people are usually
annoyed because they've been waiting if
you show up on time you give everyone
else a chance to either be early or late
and they feel good no matter which way
they are because either they were early
and prepared for you or they were late
and you were prepared for them which
makes them feel